margot robbie turns 32 and celebrates
with a barbie themed birthday party on
set
the actress who plays the iconic doll in
the upcoming live action movie was all
smiles holding a pink box of donuts and
party hat in between filming margo's
rocking barbie's roller skating outfit
underneath a white linen blouse
and no barbie party would be complete
without a barbie cake the pink
confection made with a real barbie was
marked with the message happy birthday
barbie margot so many things have
happened that i that i've still pinched
myself that i can't believe it's quite
true and even on her special day margo's
still hard at work here she is doing a
scene with her ken doll played by her
co-star ryan gosling that's the two
decked out in western inspired attire
margot in an all-pink cowgirl look and
ryan in black just one of many outfits
they've sported since the start of
filming there's been some mixed
reactions to their on-screen
transformations but one person who's
fully on board ryan's long-time partner
eva mendes i feel like my man has
started a real renaissance like a
kenneth
a kenissance is right during ava's
recent appearance on the talk she
couldn't help but fangirl over her man
as ken abbs and all i saw the photo and
the 14 year old in me was like oh yeah
but you know it's a it's a funny it's a
funny photo and he's trying to be funny
but um so it worked on all levels but i
when i saw it he sent it to me from work
and i said
can i please have that underwear
please i never asked for anything so
anyway i do have it i'm wearing it right
now
oh okay
i just
there was something about the image that
sparked like my you know that little
teenage yep that's it
so how does ryan keep his abs so
chiseled well his co-star simul liu
who's also in the film reportedly
playing a different version of ken
dished to et all about ryan's strict
regimen he's definitely like a gym in
the morning gym after work kind of guy
and i just um you know as much as i i
believe that i do have a work ethic i
also
love
food
a lot
and you know just hearing little bits
and pieces about you know just his his
strict diet regimen and just like how
you know much emphasis he puts on taking
care of himself and his body i'm like i
i respect it i respect it i'm gonna have
some soda now there's a lot of details
still under wraps about the barbie film
including the plot
even when e.t spoke with margot last
year she only teased this expect the
unexpected it's not going to be whatever
you're thinking it's not it's not that
but one thing fans should expect it'll
be bright and bold right see move i feel
like the less i tell you the better
because i feel like every little piece
of news that comes out to tease people
everyone just gets progressively more
confused and curious as to what this
movie is and i kind of like that i feel
like um i feel like july of next year
when it comes people are going to be
really really surprised
just fun just fun colors like we're
wearing bright vibrant fun celebration
[Music]
you